Libs of tick tock has this it's a video
giving teachers tips on how to make
classrooms more trans inclusive because
that of course is should be our goal
let's listen to this
hi I'm Jack my pronouns are they them
and I identify as trans and non-binary
here are three things you can do to
support trans children in your school
number one be a visible trans Ally there
are lots of ways to do this from having
trans-inclusive Flags in your classroom
to having trans inclusive storybooks on
your bookshelves number two stop
unnecessarily gendering things in your
school this ranges from Easy changes
like not grouping children into boys and
girls to not having gendered uniforms
consider how it's glueded trans and
especially non-binary children and staff
may feel about gendered spaces and
policies and number three teach children
about pronouns what they are how we use
them and why they're important
this allows trans people to not be
singled out for their pronouns and
instead makes pronouns part of the norm
you know we can make all the usual
points here that this is uh this is not
what schools are supposed to do this is
not what the classroom is for this is
not education this is a form of
religious indoctrination to promote
transgenderism in the class as a
violation of the separation of church
and state that we always
hear about it's a violation of many
other things as well but it is also
religious indoctrination
um
but rather than dwelling on those points
this time I want to make a a different
observation because there's one thing
you said that jumped out at Me Maybe
slightly subtle I don't know if you
picked up on it amid all the the usual
insanity
he said especially non-binary kids
especially so he's talking about the
challenges faced by quote trans and
non-binary kids even though there are no
such thing as trans and non-binary kids
or adults for that matter
but he's discussing the challenges or or
whatever and he says especially
non-binary
and that's because there's a there's a
shift happening we should we should take
note of this there is a shift happening
at the top of the victim pyramid and
we've talked about the victim pyramid
many times on on this show this is the
victim hierarchy there is a hierarchy of
victimhood on the left and there's
always there's there's this Perpetual
jostling and the war at the top like
who's the Uber victim
um what group can claim status as the
Uber super victims
and if you're if you're at that uh if
you're at the top of the victim
hierarchy it means that it's kind of
almost an inverted hierarchy because it
means that you cannot be guilty of
victimizing anyone else but everyone is
always victimizing you
and victim mode is power so it means
that you have power it's very it's a
very inverted upside down sort of
topsy-turvy
system but that's the system don't be
distracted by parties and presidents
this holiday season instead joined
Hallows most anticipated prayer
challenge of the Year pray 25 led by
cast members from The Chosen the largest
Christian streaming Series in history
prey 25 will guide you through
meditation and prayer for 25 days
leading up to Christmas pray 25 will
help grow your understanding of mankind
and develop a disciplined prayer habit
during a season when uh discipline is
certainly put to the test hello is the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
U.S and the number one Catholic app in
the world hello helps me make prayer a
priority and with pray 25 it can do the
same for you find peace and fortify your
faith this Christmas with hallow
download the app for free and join the
pray 25 challenge go to hello.com Matt
Walsh and get three months completely
free that's hello.com Matt Walsh to
reclaim your piece during this holiday
season but right now there's this uh
there's a this shift happening where
non-binary is slowly
replacing trans as the most favored most
protected most cherished group in fact
here's a prediction for you I I think
that trans as a category will fade away
like the category of lesbian has all but
disappeared as as because lesbians been
subsumed by trans
and uh and the same thing's gonna happen
with trans I think trans gets subsumed
by non-binary eventually it's just it
all is simply non-binary now in effect
it's the same thing it's the same brand
of insanity there's no real difference
they're both made up they're both making
essentially the same false claim but the
advantage of non-binary is that it's
even more vague it's even more
undefinable it's even more
subjective than trans
so trans still ties itself from one
thing to the very gender binary that
it's supposedly be that it's supposedly
trying to dismantle non-binary is meant
to be apart from that entirely and the
great thing for non-binary is that there
are no expectations attached to it
there's no definitions there's just like
nothing at all
it means even less than trans
and trans when you get down to it really
doesn't mean anything either of course
but but but non-binary is even more
undefinable even more uh
absurd and vague and uh it can just be
whatever you want it to be which makes
it more useful to the left it's a more
useful category
the more vague the more undefinable the
more ambiguous the category is the more
useful it is to them
so more and more that's what we're going
to start to see
it's like trans trans becomes passe it
becomes old-fashioned and the new thing
is to be non-binary that'll do it for
this portion of the show as we move over
to the members block hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]